[Applause]
foreign
hey girl uh welcome welcome to another
episode in the season finale of America
uh
I'm Jimmy Fallon for Greg Gutfeld we're
not sure what the king of late night is
up to but the way things are going in
this country he may have just gotten a
job modeling women's yoga pants for all
we know
yeah and another time a biological man
like Greg couldn't have been hot to
model women's clothes
but he probably could model children's
clothes at his height let's be honest
of course to bring up children because
Disneyland which once considered itself
the happiest place on Earth is
continuing its ongoing quest to become
the wokest place on Earth check it out
Disneyland just announced its first LGBT
Pride night in an effort to clap back
across the country at Ron DeSantis in an
ongoing culture war that started when he
passed what the left claimed was a don't
say gay Bill the only problem there is
like every other Disney story don't say
gay was a Pure Fantasy the parental
rights and Education Act didn't even
mention the word gay on any of its Six
Original Pages or in its expansion of
the bill it simply made it illegal to
teach sexual activity or sexual identity
to Children between the ages of
kindergarten and third grade because
let's face it growing up we had a word
for people who wanted to talk sex with
little kids they were called pedophiles
and DeSantis wisely pushed that crap out
of the classrooms not because he hated
gay kids or trans kids but because he
hated the idea of sexualizing kids and
you know who else didn't ask to have
adult sexualizing little kids or telling
them they were trapped in the wrong body
little kids Bingo circle gets a square
no little kid was asking to go for a
ride on Snow White and the Seven genders
nope
no little boy wanted to be Peter Pan
sexual no ma'am
and no little girl was asking to dress
up as a princess named Cinder fella
this only happens when woke parents
forced their Politics on children the
way Disney's board is forcing its
Politics on parents you see they're
trying to clap back against their own
straw man argument that DeSantis banned
gay people but hello nobody has ever
been to Key West thinks Florida banned
gay people
yo South Beach is so gay they have a
pride month for straight people
Disney claims they're carrying on with
this event in the name of inclusion but
we know that's a scam because if Disney
really cared about including as many
people as possible they wouldn't charge
120 bucks to get in you know thank you
stop it last I checked the prices we're
keeping out a lot more kids than the
pronouns Disney nope this Pride night is
a way for Disney to score points with
his wool culture Warriors while doing
what it does best which is ripping off
parents take it from a guy who knows I
took my son to Disney back in 2012 when
I was a cab driver couldn't try the food
because we couldn't get a co-signer but
the point is we had a good time
and when I got done turning tricks
behind Space Mountain my credit card was
level
sorry I've hit it home for a few people
uh
thought some of you fellas looked
familiar uh
but the point is Disney doesn't care
about inclusion because they have the
most exclusionary prices of any theme
park on the planet and don't let them
pretend they care about gay people
because Disney's streaming service does
business and over a dozen countries that
criminalize gay activity for real this
is a company that calls DeSantis a
homophobe while they squeeze every last
dollar they can out of countries where
gay behavior is punishable by fines
prison sentences and hard labor and not
the type of hard labor Chadwick Moore
offered me in the green room either
[Laughter]
Disney makes plenty of money in Saudi
Arabia which treats same-sex activity
with chemical castrations and in Yemen
where being gay is punishable by death
not to mention that Disney Cruise Lines
charge a starting price of 3 800 bucks a
person to sail to Antigua Dominica and
Saint Martin where two guys kissing will
not have a happy ending well it might
but they'll get arrested if they get
caught in the act uh so yo Disney
keep up with the group uh
so yo Disney how about instead of
hollering about don't say gay you don't
say anything because it may be a small
world after all but it's a huge double
standard in your case girlfriend and I
know desantis's Republican Rivals are
criticizing him for taking away Disney
special tax Privileges and joking that
he might build a state prison next to
the park and today Florida updated that
education bill on instruction about
sexual orientation and gender identity
and it now includes grades 4 through 12
unless the curriculum is taught in a
reproductive Health lesson now listen we
could argue for days of whether DeSantis
is taking this too far but let's not
forget where it started a governor stood
up to the outrage mob and the biggest
corporation in the state to say that he
wasn't going to let anyone sexualize
kindergarten kids they tried spinning
that into some sort of homophobia even a
bit of transphobia with zero supporting
evidence you know the old saying when
you have the facts you pound the facts
but when you have nothing you pound the
table well corporations like Disney have
been pounding the table but the joke of
it all is nobody asked them to look are
kids going to grow up to be sexual being
someday sure they are especially if R
Kelly can help it
laughs
I'm like how is he not a bail Risk by
the way he believes he can fly you know
what I mean
but seriously Disneyland is where you go
to escape adulthood even when you're
adult which is why this parent thinks
DeSantis is all the way right for
pushing back on the left's obsession
with sexualizing little kids just
because families like Toy Story doesn't
mean Disney should be trying to give our
kids a woody
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests she knows
Mark it's better than a Wuhan bat Fox
Business anchor Lauren Simonetti in the
house
Freddie Mercury is gone but he will rock
you contributing editor of The Spectator
chat with more
if ticket sales were beer his would be
Bud Light comedian Joe DeVito we love
you we love him
stop stop the staff put me up to that
you know I love you and cops used to
throw the book at her but now she's a
best-selling author you damn right she
is
cab temp is here for the win
the witch Chadwick I will go to you
first girlfriend why would you choose me
first
but for a second speaking as a gay man
let's take politics out of this for a
second explain why this is all the
left's fault
well the reaction is it's just so stupid
and pathetic I mean Disney has I mean
Disney's had a gay days for like ever so
now they're going to say we're adding a
gay night too just to stick it to you to
say it just and it's not even at the
Florida Park is it the one in California
but I and I feel like it's just such a
strong man argument I'll come to you for
a second cat we have tons of gay friends
okay
and we don't ever want a world where
they don't feel accepted or included but
don't you think pride is almost being
like misrepresented now as an Fu to half
the country who didn't have a problem
with pride I actually took a huge issue
with something you said in your
monologue that I wrote it down okay give
it to me Disneyland is where you go to
escape adulthood even when you're an
adult that's not true that's the bar I
think
[Applause]
that's alcohol I mean I I just I think
it's strange when adults go to Disney as
a recreational activity I've said this
many times and everybody who gets upset
at me for saying it proves my point when
I see like let's go to your bachelorette
party in Disneyland we can drink around
the world or for the same price you can
drink around the actual world like let's
go to Europe uh but again Chadwick like
you said I thought this is this is not
new it's like Pride if you want to like
okay that's fine it's kind of stupid
um if you were a Disney shareholder
you're a business person
um when it comes to this conflict in
this manufactured culture War would you
make like Princess Elsa and Let It Go
[Laughter]
I know at the
strange world old my four-year-old his
friend had a birthday party there and
parents actually canceled when they
found out at the movie that they were
showing because of the Crush in it the
gay Crush
um that was supposed to be a blockbuster
it failed big time two movies Disney put
out last year tanked because they're
pushing these values on Americans who
are saying yeah I'll teach my child this
when I'm ready I'm not going to take
them to like the theater and have them
be introduced to Concepts that they're
just not ready for I think people going
to the park don't really care so much
because they're there to spend an arm
and a leg and have so much fun and just
Escape but guess what Pride night you
have to pay even more for it's 140 and
it's ticketed so there is a separation
there so as a shareholder I think you
can sort of ignore it where you can
ignore it is if DeSantis wins in this
fight and some of those perks that
Disney has had for decades get pulled
away now I would love to see that
because I think it would encourage other
corporations to like chill out do you
want the prison next to Walt Disney
World
that's kind of that would be amazing
said nobody ever
Joey day uh would you care more about
this story if you were told enough to
get on the rods
[Laughter]
well for your information I like the
It's a Small World ride because the
singing dolls are the same size as me
[Applause]
four years but she kept singing the song
in the bedroom it was very awkward
uh first uh charging an arm and a leg
ableist
[Laughter]
I
I miss as much because it's an evening
event I I think it might just be for
adults so it's it's not quite the same
you can bring kids I believe yeah well
you know I don't mind a pride night a
pride day a pride dusk I got some issues
with the pride dust I don't care for
that but if you take away the children
aspect of Disney it's very creepy it's
weird because just look at the
characters you got the whole duck family
running around they're pantsless
Scrooge McDuck is rubbing his ass in a
room full of coins this is very strange
Scrooge McDuck was the original only
fans you got to get those coins and look
at um Goofy and Pluto I mean once we're
in a turtleneck the other one's got a
collar and a chain it's it's very
perverse so I I don't think it's a big
deal and I don't like when people say
what about straight Pride what about you
want to know about straight Pride take a
look at my browser history tell me what
you see there that anyone should be
proud of
but let me ask you this do you feel like
on some level I had kind of alluded this
to this earlier there's like this straw
man argument being waged that the gay
community is under attack when we are so
far past if you look at pop culture and
who's successful and who's selling and
sitcoms are they kind of weaponizing
like hijacking this in a way to kind of
make it a point of contention when one
wouldn't really exist like meaning we
don't care if gay kids go to Disney
World that's obviously not an issue yeah
yeah it's interesting because especially
now with I mean gen Z is the first
generation to come of age post-gay
marriage but basically I mean the gay
rights movement is effect it's over it's
effectively over it's totally over and
yet we've raised this generation of
people that feel like they need to be
Freedom Fighters in some respect uh at
least keyboard Freedom Fighters yeah
yeah and it's just I mean it's pathetic
and and you know it's uh they really
have nothing strong that they're
actually fighting for it's just these
silly little battles yeah and they have
to invent they have to invent what's not
there like in Rhonda Sanchez's bill in
Florida which is absolutely very
straightforward and instead of some
Builders just don't say gay and just
acting gay people total scam totally let
me let me ask you this as a parent
though because they want to tell us that
you know we need to care more about the
well-being of these children but should
anybody be lecturing us about the
well-being of children if they're
selling a 12 pound turkey leg
you know that thing
it's literally sick it looks like it's
off of velociraptor
and it's 32 for a turkey leg I think
that's why so many people are outraged
by this because they're you save for a
vacation you don't go to Disney every
year unless you live in Florida then you
might not go every year this is your
your savings you're planning and then
you go and you have to explain things to
your children and spend so much money
for for the food and at no point on the
way down uh do you fantasize about going
on a ride cold it's a small reassignment
surgery after all
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else